[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar medical laboratory performance
benchmarking current practice and future
perspectives
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott
to learn more visit core laboratory dot
abbott
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr wolfgang huff medical director vienna
health care group clinic heights in
vienna austria
dr huff you may now begin your
presentation
thank you marie for your kind
introduction and welcome again everyone
i've roughly structured this talk in the
general background a discussion of a
recent study and perspectives for
individual laboratories
first of all
my personal story
why am i such a fan
for benchmarking the short answer is it
helps to make good decisions
the long answer begins with
me being a general practitioner and
regarding laboratory
standards as very high particularly in
the age of evidence-based medicine
then i received training as a laboratory
professional which is
subjectively confirmed my view regarding
standardization in laboratories
but i also found that there is
much room for development
in particular there is a lack of
peer-reviewed data for management
decisions
what is benchmarking how can we define
it
a benchmark is something that serves as
a standard by which others may be
measured or judged according to
merriam-webster
quality
is a relative concept
as it said in medicine today's state of
the art may be tomorrow's grounds for a
trial in a court of law
to assess whether we deliver good
quality we need a reference
in clinical medicine we use guidelines
in the labora laboratory we don't have
much of that in particular regarding
management decisions
this is where benchmarking comes into
play
the laboratory traditionally focuses on
measurement quality
there is a host of external quality
assessments available and widely
established
however
there is also an increasing need to
improve quality in the interaction with
the hospital and management decisions
in particular regarding financial
sustainability
in pubmed the standard database to
research on this there is little to be
found
when you type in medical laboratory and
benchmarking as a search term there are
34 hits
to be found
you can find more on the term eqa
but this is primarily relating to topics
of measurement
right now a lot of international
conferences focus on the so-called
pre-analytical phase this is the phase
where about 65
laboratory errors occur and about 65
percent of costs incursed by the
laboratory
are
generated
so there is a need for data relevant to
management decisions
but
why isn't it here already
as i said benchmarking
either too mostly focused on instrument
and essay performance there are a few
international
studies
trying to compare different laboratories
in different countries different regions
of the world
and they most rely on so-called lis data
laboratory information system data
this is a particularly the case for
the ifcc the international federation
for clinical chemistry working groups on
laboratory errors in patient safety
which extracts
most of its data from
data that is generally to be found in
the laboratory information system there
are some questions that need to be
extracted by hand from different sources
and there are a few studies that focused
on management approaches but
they have not yet published
questionnaires
indeed we didn't find any published
questionnaire regarding
worldwide approaches to
quality and laboratory management so
there need there is a need to generate
and publish a questionnaire
what do we need to do in particular
evidence-informed decision-making is
rapidly becoming the norm
in medicine there is the so-called
european union hope program
hope is in the european hospital and
healthcare federation
2019
the theme was
evidence informed decision making and
healthcare management
and this year's theme is using evidence
in healthcare management so it directly
relates to the 2019 theme
the basic idea is to use reliable data
to support
decision making and management
you cannot
identify the exactly best decision of
course but the more data you have
the better informed your decisions in
general are
so we need to recognize the status quo
in comparison to others
and the academic approach to do this
would be to first design a questionnaire
then
design a reliable data elicitation
process
validate both in the pilot study and
then
use them widely
in particular
we should use the pdca cycle gaming
cycle plan do check act
to continuously improve such a
questionnaire
this idea was the basis for the medical
laboratory benchmarking
that
we publish recently
now why do we need the questionnaire
posing quasi-redundant questions to
elicit reliable information in the end
directly estimating one's own
performance in relation to others is not
the strength the human mind
as you can see
in the study we conducted recently about
98 of laboratories rated their
performance at or above the industry
average this is mathematically
impossible for normally distributed data
now having sketched the general
background i will proceed to talk about
a recent study
and narrow down on the challenges and
opportunities associated with
benchmarking
a benchmarking study relevant to
laboratory management and needs to cover
three key aspects
the process dimension the clinical
dimension and the financial dimension
i will now present a few questions that
were deemed relevant by a group of group
of experts
and
minded this questionnaire has already
been published
you can see the citation at the bottom
of the slide and i can always look it up
in the process dimension three examples
for questions for items actually used
was
does your laboratory measure defined key
performance indicators
examples given very employee
productivity workspace utilization
the amount of implemented auto
validation rules and so on
another example
is
which of the following turnaround times
displayed below
does your laboratory monitor
turnaround times can be defined in
various manners
most of the laboratories
use as their turnaround time the
so-called lab turnaround time
which is defined
from the beginning of sample reception
to the end of recite release
the most um
interesting turnaround time of course is
the so-called total
turnaround time that starts with the
order
and ends with the result release as more
comprehensive approach still is the
brain-to-brain turnaround time that
starts with order and events ends with
physicians access to the data
the third example
was do you use any of advanced id
functionalities listed here is where for
example smartphone related alerts and
applications
instrument capacity monitoring and
information dashboards display kpis
for the clinical dimension of laboratory
benchmarking example questions are which
of the following services does your
laboratory provide to physicians
for example results and interpretations
in combination
proactive consultation complex patient
cases
or diagnostic pathways guidance
how regular did your laboratory and
clinical care teams review the
diagnostic pathways or guidance together
in the last 12 months
or is your laboratory combining data
digitally without diagnostic disciplines
a very interesting item was also the
question regarding
the laboratory measuring impact on
patient outcomes
this is particularly seldomly used
the last but not least dimension is the
financial dimension
most of the laboratories
do not like to give away that direct
financial results
but
for a benchmarking study to be relevant
we need we need to be we need to have
some estimate about the financial
dimension
and items deemed relevant by experts for
what percentage of results are also
validated
um
how many full-time equivalents
were used to operate analytical
workstations
or
the physical space needed
to operate in a difficult workstations
as our goal in designing a study
of this kind is generating
data
that
fulfill the so-called
measurement quality criteria of
objectivity reliability and validity
we trained a host of professionals
to identify valid data in direct
one-on-one conversations
an online questionnaire was filled out
by heads of laboratories
and these trained professionals together
which assured confidentiality and
anonymity
of course there was a possibility to
give contact data to get individual
feedback
the design process of the questionnaire
was iterative
first of all there was an extensive
literature research
and then we used all the experience and
the input for informal focus groups of
laboratory professionals
to reduce
the number of items in the questionnaire
to 50
in order that the questionnaire was
short
and could generate high participation
and high completion rates
as mentioned it was essential to train
professionals to ensure consistency and
confidentiality
with the pseudonymized data
the resulting questionnaire consisted of
the three dimensions operational
performance integrated clinical care
performance and financial sustainability
there were some items regarding general
information at the beginning altogether
50 items
773 laboratories
answered the survey
as far as we know this is the
largest survey to date regarding
laboratory performance
in management
the top 10 participating countries were
italy russia saudi arabia spain united
kingdom germany greece
united arab emirates south africa and
serbia
all together
about
60 percent of laboratories were
government hospital laboratories
but fifth were private commercial
laboratories and about another fifth
private hospital laboratories there were
a few
research laboratories testing
laboratories that were excluded in the
further analysis
now how do laboratories re rate
how do laboratories rate in the three
dimensions
in all three dimensions laboratories
were about normally distributed
which is a prerequisite for the
statistical analysis we performed
afterwards
this is so called factor analysis
which
more or less automatically
sorts the individual items used in the
questionnaire into different
sub-dimensions
in the subdimension of operational
performance
we found seven items in the
sub-dimension of integrated clinical
care performance
six items and in the sub-dimension of
financial sustainability
we also found seven items
you can identify them here
and
this is basically the central figure
of the study the central plot
you can see that there is a correlation
between operation performance and
integrated clinical care performance
financial sustainability is coated in
green amber and red
there is a group of legumes
in the
lower left-hand quadrant
and a group of leaders
in the
top
right hand quadrant
but the interesting thing is the
deviation from this rule of correlation
which might be of interest to individual
laboratories there is for example one
laboratory
which is indicated with the blue arrow
that is in the upper right quadrant
rates very high in operational
performance and rates very high on
integrated care performance but
is in the lower quartile of financial
sustainability
for the individual laboratory it might
be of interest to identify
the things that could be optimized
to increase financial sustainability
and this can be done in the
self-analysis in this case
the laboratory among others
had
practically no autovalidation
in all the laboratory specialties like
clinical chemistry immunoassays
hematology urinalysis coagulation
victoriology root in molecular and
specialized molecular
in this second example
we examine the laboratory that is
above the median
in this case of integrated clinical care
performance and financial sustainability
but there's a laggards
in a sub-dimension of operational
performance
again
[Music]
we can examine the reasons for this
and we would find that
the laboratory doesn't measure patient
satisfaction
doesn't measure clinician satisfaction
and doesn't measure employee
satisfaction
furthermore
it doesn't have
any procedures relating to lean or six
sigma
the third example is a laboratory that
rates relatively high on operational
performance and financial sustainability
but
rates rather low on integrated clinical
care performance
the reason for this is for example that
it doesn't combine any data digitally
with other disciplines
so what can be done in general
for an individual laboratory
i have now
discussed the background of benchmarking
i have discussed this study
but for the individual laboratory we
need some action items the typical
approach
for your lab would be to
identify
the subscale or subscales of interest
after participating in such a
benchmarking study identify the items of
interest
in the subscales of interest
and its relative position to other
laboratories
in the country for example
or
in the specific
laboratory community like hospital
laboratories
or commercial laboratories
and then discuss with staff
and make plans for the coming year
how to improve on these measures
ideally a ptc asia cycle should be
started
the concrete action trajectories are
regarding the location of existing
resources
or
the generation of new resources budget
requests etc
the general benefits
of the benchmarking approach are that
benchmarking allows quantification and
thus comparison
and ideally business case generation
always remember that top management
needs
data to do
investment and location allocation of
resources
and they even might need some arguments
for shareholders
this is the publication to sum up
the background was that there is a
historical lack of global initiatives on
collecting and benchmarking management
data
for a diagnostic
medical laboratories
we did a study that was published in the
pilot
you saw in the slides above
and
found its follow-up study
in
the study published in clinical
chemistry and laboratory medicine that
gathered data from
all around europe middle east and africa
its aims were to establish a good
practice approach towards benchmarking
to generate the snapshot of the current
state of the art in this region
and
most importantly to set the stage for
global follow-up studies
your immediate reaction might be how to
participate in these global follow-up
studies
you can participate using this link here
and for more background information
visit the core laboratory site at evert
this was it from my part
and i'm ready to take questions now
thank you dr hoof for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
how can i be sure that my data are kept
confidential
well um
by default
data questions and processing in this
study are of course anonymized and there
are several regulations like the general
data protection regulation of the
european union
and other relevant regulations that are
natural related to
but
of course there is the opportunity
to get individual feedback if possible
and decide by the participant in this
case contact details can be given
and
data will be returned to to the
participant but data analysis per se is
always done with anonymized data
all right thank you
next question
since data are anonymous can i be sure
that they are representative for the
laboratory landscape
first of all
representativeness is a relative concept
it depends on the subgroup you're
examining
and of course there is some potential
for bias in any study
nevertheless
i already mentioned that
the study presented here is the largest
study to date
so it is probably the best you can do
right now
and
regarding utility which is uh the most
important question for each and every
individual laboratory
it's it's like with the telephone the
more people use it
the more benefit you might have
and
i hope that this webinar will also
increase participation and that's the
utility for you
great thank you
next question
how exactly do you envision benchmarking
to continue in the future
i believe benchmarking
will be
much more central
in the future of laboratory medicine
in particular i think that each
laboratory will probably not only have a
sort of chief benchmarking officer
but also higher degree of benchmarking
literacy
in the entirety of its staff
to this regard we're currently running
the follow-up study the links to which
you can see on the screen
and promoting knowledge about the
utility of benchmarking on an
international scale
all right
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
how has the benchmarking data helped
your lab
well the way benchmarking data helps the
individual lab
depends to a high degree on the current
state of development of this lab
you saw in the scatter plots that
individual laboratories have a
quite a varying degree
of
so to say majority
in our particular lab we felt the need
to increase automation and also focus
more intensely on the pre-analytical
phase in concordance
with the international conferences and
their focus on the pre-analytical phase
of course this is normal most
professionals you most of the time know
the needs of a laboratory but you don't
have the data to prove it
in discussion discussions with the
management
so
the benchmarking study was a wake-up
call call for us all
and we now strive to achieve a fully
digital ordering process as a side note
during the current pandemic
the city of vienna has impressively
demonstrated
a full electronic ordering process
for the masses so
it should be achievable by any
laboratory worldwide
all right thank you dr huff do you have
any final comments for our audience
well i enjoyed the webinar and thank you
for the great questions
have a nice day
thanks thank you again dr huff for your
time today in your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
you